celle ci auger et manon globensky c'est
le caucus dans le balade au caucus
michels et augé et manon globensky
décortique les moments marquants de la
semaine politique
ils sont entourés de la meilleure équipe
puisqu'ils peuvent faire appel aux
analystes et au correspondant de radio
canada partout au pays et dans le monde
on va plus loin que la nouvelle aude
voici pourquoi ça s'est passé comment ça
se fait quels ont été les influences
quels ont été les gens qui ont gagné qui
ont perdu par jour des batailles
internes dans les dents les
gouvernements du pénis l'amérique les
élections américaines promettent d'être
captivant jusqu'au bout pour choisir les
sujets de que dieu bénisse l'amérique le
paradou décrivent radio versant des
sureaux auront l'embarras du choix dans
cette campagne pleine de rebondissements
confère au temps du plus poussée avec
l'analyse un peu plus intense a vraiment
des experts que des sections plus
politique sensé c'est que ce soit
accessible pour tous tout le monde
apprenne quelque chose qu'elle gabri
nadeau-dubois bienvenue à cette
troisième saison du comité des idées
dangereuses
le coporte-parole de québec solidaire
gabriel nadeau dubois au lui aussi été
séduit par les nouveaux médias qui signe
depuis quelques temps le comité des
idées dangereuses et moi ça me manquait
d'avoir un espace de réflexion de débat
où on peut prendre le temps d'aller au
bout une question c'est le 17 octobre
cette année marque le 50e anniversaire
de la crise d'octobre dans le bal à dos
pour l'avoir vécu à marie dussault et
marc laurendeau reviennent avec un
regard personnel sur ces événements
céder à leurs micros que l'ex felquiste
jacques 7 trudel affirmé que paul rose
voulais qu'ils tuent jane the witch
cross c'est une grande leçon de
démocratie
la crise d'octobre parce que nos
institutions étaient parfois ébranlé
parfois manipulée et c'est important de
retenir ces événements là pour éviter
qu'il ne se reproduise
pour l'avoir vécu caucus que dieu
bénisse l'amérique
le comité des idées dangereuses quatre
balles à dos pour les mordus de
politique
à écouter même confiné ici nabi
alexandre charti radio-canada moret